Інвестиції у сонце!
Центральна частина міста Славутич з висоти пташиного польоту виглядає геть інакше,
ніж з землі. Тут на дахах трьох будівель розмістили сонячні електростанції.
Це перший в Україні муніципальний енергетичний кооператив "Сонячне місто".
Його засновник Андрій Зінченко ідею спільного інвестування в енергетичний проект
запозичив із Європи, де такий формат фінансування поширений у багатьох сферах.
Я цікавився енергетичними кооперативами буквально ще з 2013 року,
тобто я довго їх спочатку проповідував і казав:
люди, можна таке робити в Україні, тобто можна володіти
електростанцією, можна скинутися невеликими внесками
і можна мати собі цей об’єкт.
Спільнотні енергетичні об’єкти, як на мене, це дуже правильно,
особливо коли йдеться про малі енергетичні проекти,
які не настільки цікаві банкам, але які, скажімо так, приносять конкретну користь на місці.
Аби зібрати необхідні 4 мільйони гривень на побудову електростанцій,
у серпні 2018 Андрій ініціював кампанію з залучення учасників кооперативу.
Пріоритетне право інвестувати в проект отримали жителі Славутича.
Мінімальний внесок склав 15 тисяч гривень.
Саме стільки два роки тому вклав у "Сонячне місто" Анатолій Раєвський.
На дах зі станцією чоловік виходить уперше.
Сума інвестування невелика, ну, і звісно,
заробіток буде теж маленьким, але питання не грошах.
Для дітей, якщо цей кооператив буде 10, 20, може, 100 років працювати, -
вони будуть отримувати ці маленькі кошти.
Ну, і як реклама для інших міст і для нашого міста, для інших жителів.
Усього членами кооперативу стали майже сто людей та декілька юридичних компаній,
а три сонячні станції з сумарною потужністю 200 кіловат за рік
здатні згенерувати приблизно 250 тисяч кіловат-годин електроенергії.
Це пристрої, які перетворюють постійний струм у змінний струм -
той, що може йти вже в мережу.
Фотовольтаїчні модулі дають постійний струм,
а ось це і це -
два шістдесятикіловатні інвертори.
Увесь згенерований на дахах струм енергетичний кооператив віддає в загальну електромережу.
Держава зобов’язана купити його за так званим "зеленим" тарифом, який нині в Україні
найвищий у Європі і складає приблизно 16 євроцентів за кіловат-годину.
Андрій Зінченко розраховує, що з кожної вкладеної в СЕС тисячі євро
інвестори щорічно отримуватимуть приблизно 130 євро чистого прибутку.
Міський голова Славутича пояснює, чому подібні кооперативи
можуть бути вигідні іншим містам.
Це економічно вигідно тим, хто вкладає,
тому що там є прибуткова частина.
Це економічно вигідно місту, тому що є соціальна частина.
5% прибутку йде на міські проекти, які ми визначаємо.
Здебільшого це проекти з енергоефективності, і там є мультиплікаційний ефект,
і це можливості залучення інвестицій.
Сонячні панелі були інстальовані на дахах в Славутичі та підключені до мережі
ще в грудні минулого року, комерційну ж генерацію кооператив "Сонячне місто"
розпочав тільки два тижні тому. Нині ж уряд веде перемовини
з виробниками енергії з відновлюваних джерел про зниження зеленого тарифу.
За словами Андрія Зінченка, це вплине на роботу галузі в цілому
і його кооперативу зокрема.
Для таких станцій, як наша, за тими меморандумами,
які були опубліковані урядом, передбачається зменшення зеленого тарифу на 2,5%.
А для більшості інших станцій, які були введені минулими роками,
там хочуть забрати 15%, наприклад. Якщо зараз
відбудеться все те, що уряд рапортує як перемогу,
звісно, на нас чекає провал в інвестуванні на наступні роки у відновлювані джерела енергії.
Поки що в планах уряду не йдеться про зменшення зеленого тарифу за енергію,
згенеровану домашніми сонячними електростанціями.
А за останні півтора року їхня кількість зросла майже втричі і нині складає 24 тисячі.
Ось там у нас були рядки з картоплею.
Це замість картоплі у нас тепер тут сонячні батареї.
Олександр Сокіржинський почав активно встановлювати сонячні панелі
на своєму городі, будинку й обійсті п’ять років тому.
За цей час у загальну  електромережу за зеленим тарифом
він віддав понад 100 тисяч кіловат-годин електроенергії, згенерованої сонцем.
Прибутки від домашньої СЕС чоловік не рахує.
Його більше тішить енергонезалежність власної оселі.
Генерація складає десь 35 тисяч кіловат-годин на рік.
Річне споживання цієї ділянки складає десь 18-20 тисяч кіловат-годин на рік.
Тобто ми енергонезалежні.
Фінансово автономна ця ділянка.
Оці сонячні батареї працюють для споживання дому.
А ось ті сонячні батареї забезпечують автономію автомобіля.
Тобто я ще й їжджу безкоштовно за рахунок сонячних батарей.
Якісь гроші вільні є - це найкраща інвестиція.
За підрахунками Олександра, середня вартість встановлення сонячних батарей
нині складає 700$ за кіловат електроенергії.
Таким чином можна розраховувати на окупність інвестицій протягом 4-5 років.
Люди зрозуміли: енергія сонячна працює.
Це розуміння поширюється.
Для людини встановити 10-кіловатну сонячну станцію
коштуватиме приблизно 6-7 тисяч доларів.
І мати енергетичну незалежність - це дуже гарна інвестиція і дуже гарний інструмент.
Нині держава має зобов’язання викуповувати
всю згенеровану енергію за зеленим тарифом до 2030.
Однак ці умови вже не виконуються,
і затримка виплат за альтернативну енергію в окремих регіонах складає 3-4 місяці.
Окрім того, за словами експертів, обсяг енергії, яку генерують відновлювані джерела,
не можна передбачити. Її надлишок чи дефіцит у мережі
балансується за рахунок інших традиційних джерел.
Якщо не буде законодавчих змін, то всі власники СЕС
можуть користуватися можливістю їх встановлення до 2030 року.
Можуть відбутися зміни, оскільки існуючі мережі Укренерго
не спроможні прийняти стільки енергії загалом від різних мереж і передати до споживача.
Плюс її необхідно балансувати і ми потрапляємо у такий своєрідний:
відновлювально-вугільний парадокс:
чим більше ми будуємо відновлюваних джерел енергії,
тим більше треба вугілля або газу для того, щоб їх балансувати у моменти,
коли закрилося сонце хмарами або немає вітру.
За даними Державного агентства з енергоефективності та енергозбереження,
у невеликі сонячні електростанції українці вже інвестували майже півмільярда євро.
Такі СЕС здатні генерувати об’єм екологічної чистої електроенергії,
достатній для забезпечення приблизно 230 тисяч сімей.
Частка ж електроенергії, згенерованої усіма відновлюваними джерелами,
наразі становить близько 8%.
За енергетичною стратегією України держава має намір
збільшити цей показник до 25% у наступні 15 років.
Експерти переконані, це може стати можливим,
тільки якщо буде знайдено рішення щодо накопичення
"зеленої" енергії та правильного її балансування.